[Music]
take a seat
the quarter-final real battle
hi I'm Maxine more from FX guide.com for
Wired in the film Ender's Game the hero
of enderwiggin needs to orchestrate
complex almost operatic battles to
defeat the threatening formics earlier
in the film while still in training in
battle score of floating space station
that hovers above Earth and Ascan Pete's
in war games with fellow students these
complex battles are ballets themselves
that had to be choreographed by the
director Gavin hood Ender's Game like
the film gravity before it he's had to
solve the problem of floating in space
they've done this by shooting actors on
wires but primarily only using their
faces step through that gate and you're
in a zero-g environment battle school
was a great visual challenge in this
black dome I feel like I'm out in space
and of course when you're making a movie
you want two things you want great
characters at a great story and you want
fantastic big visuals from your final
simulation if I win tomorrow you'll be
the finest commander we've ever trained
so why do these films digitally replace
their actors leaving just there
originally filmed faces on CG bodies
well the problem of the director and the
visual effects supervisor had to solve
is one of physics and balance
[Music]
most weightless movement in films is
simulated with elaborate wire rigs the
problem is that these rigs need to be
pivoted around the waist of the actor
the actor is standing up straight this
is the correct center of their mass the
problem is that this would be fine if
the actor didn't have to end or well
accurately but as soon as the actor
bends their body the center of mass
actually shifts away from the body and
this is something that a wire rig just
can't emulate elaborate tricks are often
used to try and solve this including
literally puppeteering the actors
themselves but in the end the solution
is often just to line up the shot on an
actor on a soundstage and then fully
replace their bodies with digital
versions which can be adjusted to match
zero gravity's real physics which begs
the question why not just make their
entire bodies and their faces digitally
we asked the director this very question
while it is true that Digital Domain the
effects house did provide some fully
digital performances on the whole it is
still actually a lot cheaper to not have
to do human faces in CG and just remain
true to the original performance of the
actor but don't forget to subscribe if
you want more behind the scenes action I
might say more for
[Music]